all right laina you are on the cover of
sports illustrated
swimsuit edition how does it feel
oh my god it is a monthly time
a moment in time human evolution is
leaping into the future i mean did you
have any clue that you would be on the
cover
um not really i mean it's it's honestly
it's any girl could get the option or
get the opportunity to do it
um i just felt like i just feel like
you know i just was living every single
day and it brought me to this moment and
hear it
it arrived so i you can't adjust you get
to just receive it and just love it and
just say
we're all beautiful and but this history
moment
oh my god like it's just it's
it's so beautiful to be alive to see all
this happen
and megan italian and naomi osaka also
like
we talked about that for a sec like not
only are you on the cover of this iconic
issue but you're sharing this honor
with two baddies megan stallion and
naomi osaka three beautiful black women
yeah that is paranormal if you could
describe how you're feeling in one word
what would it be
immortalized
yes because this is forever yeah it is
i could leave we could nothing's
problems tomorrow but this stays here on
earth
amen so what was your reaction when you
heard that you'd be sharing this honor
with uh
megan and naomi well i was getting like
interviews from guru
google alerts like all week it was like
megan and zionist
she's been she's rumored to be on the
cover um lena and bloom is also making
history so i just was like
megan the stallion like sell all the
copies like i'm in it they're going to
see me they're going to see all of us
but megan is dying oh my god
when i was there being you know talking
with tyra
which was the original first woman of
color on the cover
in 1997 when she presented to me she
played it so cool she was like
oh how does it feel to be the magazine
one day you'll be in the carver and here
comes
mj with the ipad
[Music]
and it's just something like that you
just really don't expect because i
wasn't expecting i was like i'm fine
with just being in the magazine i'm fine
with just being a rookie
let's work on being a rookie of the year
like let's see if that's the potential
and when they surprised me i just knew
that the world was going to change in
that moment i knew that this was part of
the change that we needed to see for
representation everywhere so
it was just it's something that you
don't dream of you just kind of
live well you're living for sure and you
know you mentioned it tyra banks she
made history
back in the 90s breaking barriers then
and you're making history now as the
first trans woman to cover
si swimsuit edition what does that mean
to you but also what does that mean to
all those young trans
kids who are going to be able to see you
on this cover it's just that we're in a
different time
you know like we are able bodies we are
being represented on mainstream media
and mainstream
platforms where we can just see
ourselves
and see the reflection of who we are and
know that we are being cherished
amongst all those spaces so we just
gotta honestly
just keep moving in this direction like
right here
you know this is what the future looks
like this conversation these moments so
we just gotta honestly brace ourselves
and just honestly just
all thrive together brace ourselves but
also
embrace others right like do you have a
favorite
si swimsuit cover of all time there's
been so many
iconic photographs in this issue do you
have a favorite that comes to mind
tyrus obviously because it's my dad's
favorites and that's when i first saw
the polka dot bikini
like it was it's just the waist
the hair the body the skin the melanin
the beach
like that was my dad's magazine and i
saw it so
i was actually reading that magazine
looking into my future so it would have
to be that one because that's the first
one i saw
have you gotten the reaction from your
family yet on this cover
um i actually they told me not to tell
anyone but my dad
my dad actually what i told him he was
like i was like dad guess what he's like
you got the cover up
it's like how did you out how did you
know daddy he did
he just honestly the advice that he told
me he was like stay humble
love yourself and bring your whole
family and all your friends with you
enjoy this moment together all at the
table let's all celebrate this together
as a family
and that's to me that's all i need is a
year how are you celebrating this is a
big deal
oh next week we are going to be in
florida
we are going to be celebrating this
cover this
moment um sports illustrated 2021 and
right after that i'm headed to cabo
mexico where my dad lives and i'm going
to celebrate with him on his birthday
so i'm bringing him a cover and i'm
saying i love you happy birthday and
thank you for this opportunity
and that's that's all i need oh you
better sign that cover for him too you
better sign it
well i mean he birthed me to put on his
phone
already it's i mean i was raised by a
single parent who loved me who cherished
me
who saw how beautiful i was before
anyone else did and he just put me on
the path to just fly
and that's exactly what i did you know
we can't talk about representation
without talking about
pose and we need to talk about your
friggin
fierce appearance on season three i was
totally gagged
of how proud were you to see the show
get showered with so much love this last
week with the emmy nominations
oh my god it was i mean we
we needed this the first season like
this show is mine
is monumental you know for culture for
popular culture it's so rich and
you really get to see where the fantasy
of entertainment comes from and where
it's rooted in
so to be a part of that is truly truly
mind-blowing
and for me to be on that show i was
honestly just paying homage to all the
ballroom women
that came before me that also are with
me today and that are still living here
that inspired me to go after my dream so
um i wanted to pay homage to them carmen
extravaganza tenei
ajinay tracy africa those women that i
grew up loving so
to be able to play them in a beautiful
way to remind them that
i see you i saw you and i'm inspired by
you and now i get to pay homage to you
it was just universe saying this is full
circle enjoy this moment and do it for
them
well you did it the category was fish
you were stunning
it was amazing it was so good and what
an amazing season
mermaid fish right right uh you were
also featured in a film that premiered
at the tribeca film festival this past
year
i'm just excited to learn and hear
what's next for you
um what's next for me i am literally
going to take every single second
by second minute by minute day by day
and i'm just going to enjoy this ride
like i said in the beginning
time is in the essence of right now and
tomorrow is not promised so i just have
to live in this moment
but there's so many exciting things
coming out there's so many
more history being made and i just want
to honestly just
love every second and um just
enjoy it you know what what do we got to
do to get you in meg the stallion's next
music video that's what should be next
um she's gonna be i mean check us out
this saturday
in florida so you may never know
she just reposted me on her story i went
crazy i'm getting text messages from
everybody so
it's really be it's really about to be a
body yada yada yada yada
yeah it's about to be about great summer
yes yes
well the sky's the limit for you and i
can't i'm just so excited for you
and what this means for all of us so
thank you and
i can't wait to see what you do next
girl thank you so much i'm so happy
and this has been such an honor and
thank you so much et thank you so
[Music]
much
you